Chris Pratt and Olivia Munn enjoy a  romantic dinner date I better I better  man up here you know the Jurassic world  star was spotted dining with Olivia at  Hollywood hotspot Craig's restaurant in  West Hollywood on Friday according to an  eyewitness the 38 year old actor and the  37 year old actress were alone and quote  totally romantic the eye witness tells  et Chris even had his arm around her at  one point and the two weren't trying to  hide their PDA just crank it up as hot  as possible yeah Chris and Olivia have  been friends for some time they used to  hang out as couples when Monday today  all star Aaron Rodgers and Pratt was  still with wife on a ferris oh you'll  friendliest couples yes this right yes  we do know each other we hung out et has  reached out to Pratt and Munz reps for  comment  [Music]  you